[Musique]
les traditions se perdent
et pourtant pourtant dans ce petit
village de picardie à l'occasion de
pâques les enfants ressortent très celle
des batteries pour remplacer les cloches
parti à rome les enfants parcourent pas
si les rues du village ans honore les
anges et luce et en annonçant les
offices religieux
ici non seulement la tradition n'a pas
disparu comme presque partout le
tailleur mais elle a évolué d'abord
réservé aux enfants de choeur la
procession s'est ouverte à tous les
garçons du village
et puis cette année au petit fils c'est
la première année c'est pas moi me
mettre le radical et de la malaisie
alors au départ mes garçons voulaient
pas du tout des filles je ne crois pas
que votre foi j'aurais eu le droit
d'aller barclays a su les garçons c'est
maintenant fini garçons c'est tout est à
peu près pareil je crois à partir du
jeudi saint au soir il n'y a plus de
cloche dans les églises en signe du
deuil de la mort jésus-christ son
arrestation et de sa mort et les enfants
de choeur dans certains villages tous
les enfants passaient dans les rues pour
annoncer les offices religieux avec des
objets en bois des crécelles
moi j'ai toujours connu cette tradition
mais mes grands-parents parlait déjà il
ya sûrement plus d'un siècle
c'était il ya plus de 60 ans et pourtant
ils n'ont pas oublié soir le thoër nous
aviez jugeant le 20 ans 22 ans 23 jan il
a été leur conduite bien avec lucia
tourné au soir puis la danse le veto aux
6 au 8 mai au matin il travaillait
encore à quelle heure ça commence la
discipline s'est amoindrie
c'était le bon temps lâché clochard les
albums et les oeufs vous en donner et
oui comme toute peine mérite salaire le
samedi de pâques les enfants passent
dans chaque maison on leur donne des
oeufs et quelques sous qu'ils se
partageront tout alain rien dans les
chansons vient dans les attitudes n'a
changé depuis plusieurs siècles on est
bien loin des magnifiques jeux en
chocolat vendu dans un magasin ici c'est
presque une image du passé
mêlant proches y aura-t-il encore de
vrais oeufs de pâques pendu par de
vraies poules élevées au vrai grain les
vieux qui ont vu tant de choses
disparaître n'y croient pas tellement
parce bien formés caldoches et il semble
que l'origine des oeufs de pâques c'est
le fait que à cette période de l'année
et un renouveau général y compris dans
la ponte et chez les poules commence à
répondre à rythme plus le plus rapide
mais pour ne compte pas toujours
maintenant je pense toujours avec tout
est chargé
[Musique]